das semester hat gerade erst begonnen
und schon gehen studierende auf die
barrikaden
der protest richtet sich gegen die
rückkehr bernd klug es als professor an
der uni hamburg der allgemeine
studierendenausschuss asta hatte zu der
demonstration aufgerufen der afb gründe
habe mitverantwortung für die heutigen
gesellschaftlichen verwerfungen wir
kritisieren andern lucke dass er über
zwei jahre lang als vorsitzender der fdp
als bürgerliches aussage stellt dieser
partei rechtsradikale strömung innerhalb
der partei maßgeblich mitgetragen hat
auch wenn sie natürlich nicht gefördert
hat und bekämpft hat er hat dennoch die
verantwortung dass diese partei sich in
diese richtung entwickelt hat die kritik
an lukas rückkehr in den lehrbetrieb
teilen viele der studierenden aber
längst nicht alle haltung die er halt
zur politik und sozialpolitik hat geht
halt natürlich indirekt auch auf seine
studenten studierenden über und das ist
halt kritisch zu sehen was halt jetzt
vielleicht wichtig wäre es dass
vielleicht bernd lucke mal sich ganz
klar noch mal distanziert von der after
oder sowas damit er hier an der uni
wieder ganz normal ankommen kann er ist
jetzt professor für makroökonomie und er
wird uns jetzt nicht irgendwie politisch
indoktrinieren es geht an sich um
makroökonomie damit wir das thema
verstehen und das war es auch
der volkswirtschaftler ließ die
professur wegen seiner wahl ins eu
parlament ab 2014 huhn und war nach
innerparteilichen querelen bereits 2015
aus der afc ausgetreten schriftlich
verweist luca auf sein bemühen die afg
als bürgerlich konstruktive kraft in
klarer abgrenzung von populismus oder
gar extremismus zu positionieren
von der zuständigen hamburger
wissenschaftssenatorin gab es zum fall
lucke nur eine kurze stellungnahme
im hörsaal eskaliert die situation dann
lücke wird ausgebuht und niedergeschrien
es kommt zu tumulten und gerangel die
vorlesung wird abgebrochen
als geschämt habe ich das empfunden ja
also für eine exzellenzuniversität dass
ein professor dort anderthalb stunden
lang niedergebrüllt wird und als
[ __ ] beschimpft wird
sichtlich angefressen verlässt lucke den
uni campus zur vorlesung in der nächsten
woche will er aber wieder kommen